people always like Gary but how do I  know Tick Tock will be here in five  years I'm like well when you bought  trillion dollar commercials on Seinfeld  you weren't trying to guess when they  were going to end the show you didn't  need NBC to promise you that friends  would play Forever you just bought ads  on Friends when the attention was on  friends so for me I'm on emotional I  don't give a [ __ ] about Tick Tock  Facebook YouTube Instagram if they all  disappeared off the face of the Earth  I'd be pumped because all that attention  would have to go somewhere and I think  most people would struggle to figure out  where and that's my favorite thing to do